[Music]
what a Grammy night daddy director and
I'm Cassie Tyler we are fresh off the
red carpet we just watched the show how
you feeling no I'm hyped are you talking
about this once we wrap the red carpet
the injury you're gonna be filled with
adrenaline excitement for me it's two
years I actually we just had to have our
glam team come back on set to fix my
makeup boy I was in tears because Kacey
Musgraves just took home album of the
year in addition to country album of the
year unbelievable moment for her for
women in country music someone who has
stuck to their roots with the lack of
support from country country radio and
is able to take home this Grammy guys a
copy album hasn't won Album of the year
in nearly 12 years the last person to do
it was the Dixie chick I will see you
know album of the year this year the top
four general categories they expanded
the number of nominees from five to
eight so for us all week long all month
long however long the nomination has
been has been out they've been out it's
been hard to predict who's gonna win and
we had a couple horses in this race no
pun intended but the high horse won two
gold an hour on the way to Las Vegas I
was driving through the desert y'all
look at nothing y'all this is a vibe
this album was just pitch perfect from
beginning to end yeah the crazy thing is
though is when Casey took home country
album of the year a little bit earlier
in the night we kind of talked about we
said is this gonna take away from album
of the year we thought maybe the
Recording Academy would give her the
love there but not in the general field
proving everyone wrong although I feel
like I always knew deep down in my heart
she had a really good shot at that and
just like I said what it means for her
as a
artists as a woman in country radio or
country music but also as a songwriter
because this album puts her songwriting
in her storytelling on full freaking
display I mean a couple of her songs
were literally written while she was on
an acid porch outside her house and you
know this album Golden Hour really dives
into I don't want to say genre blending
but she does have like the the pop disco
vibes to it she writes in a uniquely KC
way right didn't conform to anybody
else's wishes of hey maybe you shouldn't
do this or shouldn't do that she wrote
what she wanted she's saying what she
wanted and look she just got a Grammy
for and she and you talk about the
genre-bending
write two of them she mentioned that you
know she is country through and through
that is never gonna change but with this
album she took some liberties she wanted
throw a little disc guys wander through
because that is hurt that is I literally
think her blood is made of glitter
listen she energy that is her she had a
good showing two albums ago with her
debut album right she won her first
Grammy then the next one I guess the
Academy a Recording Academy kind of
slept on there and then she came back
sure what tough competition like that's
another reason why I got to give it up
to Casey because right up against some
heavy hitters you had a lot he beat
Frank I mean the Black Panther album you
know to me and I thought too but you
know there were you know I I do have to
say though out loud that it's another
year that hip-hop was a little slighted
by the Recording Academy I mean we
haven't had a hip-hop album win album of
the year since Outkast and I think it
was 2004 I was wondering if this was the
year to do it given just how so how
culturally relevant and how socially
conscious albums like the Black Panther
album were right you don't mean even
Drake's to some extent but what Janelle
Monae Brandi Carlile like there were so
many important records on here about
country album sluggers twelve years so I
mean finally giving country some love to
and we know guys that the Grammys are
subjective I think Drake even know what
you think about Kacey Musgraves taking
album of the year this is how I feel
about
I know babe
cheers to Grammys not you guys and also
this is my sparkling water ceremony rock
survives a little over three hours and
we finally we tallied up all of the
artists who won what how many did they
win two artists top the night childish
gambino and Kasey Musgraves who both
took home four Grammys she's got a dust
off some room in her house and one of
them actually bothered to show up Casey
Josh where were you buddy Donald it was
a big night you know I was hoping to see
him no but he did take two of the top
prizes for sure which we'll get into in
just as many but you guys we got to talk
about the opening of the Grammys miss
Alicia Keys the host brought out Gaga
Jada Pinkett Smith J Lo and Michelle now
I know why when we couldn't get in to
the top of the carpet when we were
trying to do our jobs cuz there were so
much security there were dogs sniffing
everywhere there were cops who were
taking you know things underneath cars
checking them now I know why Michelle
Obama was in the building I mean an
amazing amazing moment and in case you
guys missed it we have it for you right
here who runs the world
[Applause]
the message you love your sisterhood I
love y'all I love that she says who run
the who run the world girls because you
know we have to know obviously Alisha is
a woman hosting six out of the eight
best new artist nominees were women The
Recording Academy had two lovely women
holding down their red carpet live
stream it was just a night of girl power
the tribute to Dolly Parton the tribute
to Aretha Franklin Diana Ross all of
that female power right there on me on
the stage that music
music's biggest night I can't even be so
sure it's the Recording Academy making
good Duleep I made light of it a little
bit during her Best New Artist speech
when last year he said when when all the
top categories were dominated by men
right Neil portnow The Recording Academy
president I said well I think women need
to step up you know and so clearly they
stepped up and they showed out tonight
you don't know Alicia Keys showed out
you guys it was truly you know the woman
of the night I will say besides Kacey
Musgraves hosting and performing I mean
the stage was her home most of the night
like doing double-duty look at this
literally had to different be Etta
double-duty literally I mean this is a
woman who has 15 Grammys to her name
also she knows the room wow the vibe I
will say I was surprised by how much
they're putting her to work we were look
fuse though why she was covering her
eyes when she was presenting some stuff
and reading off the prompter I was like
half of her face was hidden I'm like you
can't do Alicia like that oh you can't
but she brought the but she did a good
job I will say that she got Michelle
Obama to the Grammy a guys fun fact you
know apparently it was so loud when
Michelle Obama stepped onto that stage
the crowd was going nuts that she
couldn't she could barely speak cause
she could barely hear I mean everyone
was going absolutely insane from
Michelle and rightfully so and Alicia's
performance as we have to like give a
little love right there too because they
were so good like kind of doing samples
of everyone else's music covers
everybody the pregnancy was like record
of the Year winners maybe it's a
sprinkle in some of the song of the Year
nominees and stuff I think it was song
of the you're not to because she's
saying boot up by element
yeah so anyways it was an amazing well
one of tonight's big winners was one not
many people expected to show up which
was Drake although I expected him to be
there because I was at Graeme rehearsals
for the performances on Friday and I saw
his I saw his placement on the seat and
I was talking to some of the execs at
the Recording Academy they're like yeah
we're so thrilled to have him this year
a lot of people didn't expect him to be
there but I like is this like a secret
that I just kept I know that right
apparently I told you and you doubted me
I'm like dude I was like I don't think
he's coming like were their seats show
me the receipt I literally had you you
didn't trust my words my eyes I saw it
for me I thought it had a lot to do with
two things one Kent Earl Rick the
Grammys executive producer told the New
York Times that both Drake and Kendrick
turned down performances an opportunity
to perform at the Grammys and I think
there has been and I mentioned this
before you know hip hop is getting a bad
rap no pun intended at the Grammys you
know especially in these top categories
and so Ken had mentioned in that New
York Times article that he's like you
know apparently we're not giving enough
love to hit rap and like they're you
know now they're kind of backing out
backing down from showing up at the
Grammys you didn't have Jean would you
this year you know Chavez Gambino at the
same time though Drake did show up mmm I
mean we knew if you was gonna show that
he wouldn't do like the red carpet or
anything like the other thing I didn't
see him on that red carpet no he's right
he pulls a jay-z and Beyonce and somehow
he gets inside with not one person
noticing well you did get away with one
Grammy let's listen to a little bit of a
speech look the point is you've already
won if you have people who are singing
your songs word for word if you're a
hero in your hometown
if look look if there's people who have
regular jobs who are coming out in the
rain in the snow
spending their hard-earned money to buy
tickets to come of your shows you don't
need this right here I promise you out
you already learned see I drink dropping
a little bit of truth here I'm like it's
all subjective you know I'm sure if you
guys had it your way you might pick
someone else to win that I don't mean
but it was nice for him to give some
credit to
other artists being like no no the win
is your fans the win is that success you
know what is crazy to me so when I was
also at the rehearsals on Friday night
so Dan and Shay they had just finished
their rehearsal for tequila right and
then their next duty was to present best
rap song and so when you do it obviously
they do kind of like a full run-through
of that moment in the show and with Fame
and [ __ ] with fake winners who come out
of exactly where Drake came out of
people who come up from seats to you
know just so they can get all the shots
for the camera and dan + Shay literally
called out and the winner goes to God's
plan Drake and I literally was like
they're not gonna announce the winners
here at the rehearsals but it looks like
they spoke that into existence a little
bit they did but when they when you saw
them announcing other categories did
they match up tonight to be honest I
don't remember okay
I'll think about that one again because
I only caught two rehearsals it happened
to be just a coincidence I do believe on
the nominations list
I believe he's at the very top and so I
think that's how they were doing it who
ever happened to be at the very top
that's the one they would read I just
find it very ironic it is very listen
Drake won his fourth Grammy tonight but
you know what they were Recording
Academy see me up a little short a lot
of people have between about including
of all people sindbad sindbad wrote do
they just country oh this is actually
another one it says soon as Drake said
you don't need this the Grammys got
vexed oh I can't can't make out who
tweeted that but here's another reaction
[Music]
did they just cut Drake off damn I was
diggin what he was listed in Drake's
defense they cut off a lot of people
tonight but if that show went almost
three a half hours live all right you
guys moving on to another category that
got lots of buzz
song of the year went to this is America
by Childish Gambino aka Donald Glover I
was really sad that he was not there
because I had so many questions for him
but alright exactly I wanted to know if
this is a swan song okay I know right
something tells me because you know he
has said reportedly
that this is the last temporary project
so I wanted to get the answer sure well
you know what you can't get rid of
donald glover he's too good he is - he's
a creative force i feel like he's gonna
merge us something else but if this is
his swan song what a way to go right
this is such an important song and
amazing music video which also won a
grammy tonight i just felt like what it
did for culture but also just the effect
it had on people i gotta watch this
twice because you really understand it
you know that and it just was so
visceral
you know what I mean it also won record
of the year I mean was such a huge huge
night for him again he wasn't there to
accept it but I think it went - I think
it also showed a switch in the Grammys
you know I mean I think they finally are
recognizing some really socially
conscious right
music that matters the music is exactly
as we mentioned earlier though it was
definitely a great night for women at
the Grammys and for cardi B in
particular as she took home her first
Grammy for Best Rap Album for invasion
of privacy the rapper also performed her
song Monday off the album so you know
and she has a lot to be proud of tonight
and you could tell how how just proud
she was and genuinely surprised to be on
it she would when they panned to her
when she won and I love seeing artists
like that so overcome with emotion and
we were like oh my god is she gonna kiss
off so she's gonna kiss I know that's
what I was looking it was a hug but you
could say it was it was a moment of
pride before I feel like both of them my
favorite was off sets reaction to her
Grammy performance let's take a let's
take a look at what he was reacting to
first before we go to his face but this
is car to be performing money
okay you see that here is tongue out I
mean I can only imagine what he's
thinking right there oh you said it you
said it when we were watching it he's
like okay thank Rd are gonna celebrate
tonight
dad sure you know what last year car D
was pregnant at the Grammys this year
something I know why they do a lot of
all right they do a lot of selling baby
kissing on the red carpet so you know a
picture tells a thousand words she told
et's Kevin Frazier back at the soup okay
there are a few things out something
tells me there are almost there almost
back oh ma but what I was gonna say is
like you know she was pregnant last year
this year something tells me cardi is
turning up after these Grammy wins and
that performance which by the way though
a lot of y'all pointed out I saw it too
was she lip-synching oh maybe there was
a delay singing but but but then I
suspended my disbelief because I
currently shine is putting in work and
then as Britney says like when you when
you're doing that all of that look at
that yeah I can't all right we have to
give huge congratulations to do a Lipa
who took home Best New Artist they still
want to feel like always like a
crapshoot like it could have gone to
anybody but she had a lot of momentum
going in to this award show I could not
be more thrilled for her also shout out
to do because she was nominated for her
first two Grammys won both okay you
talked to her at the gram I did like a
couple months ago yes I talked to her I
think it was at the end of last year at
the Grammy Museum and this was before
the nominations were announced and I
asked her what it would mean to take one
home eventually and she goes it would
just be an honor to be nominated and I
just felt like in her answer she didn't
want to jinx it Cask felt like she was I
was like Dean you are you are really
humble about this well girl now that you
got your two Grammys how do you feel
well I found out firsthand when I talked
her on the red carpet just moments
before she moments after she found out
that she won Best Dance Recording check
it out
when I talked to her at the Grammy
Museum you were very humble about what a
nomination would mean but now you're a
winner
how does it feel crazy I just honestly I
still feel like I'm like flirting on a
cloud I still can't quite believe it
it's still so surreal
I'm gonna need a couple days to process
it and honestly I only just found out
and I'm still it's taking me a second
I'm surprised you still have your makeup
together because you cried during the
not know my last interview I my makeup
is like literally slowly fading away at
the end because my eyes are watering and
I'm really trying to hold it together
just just while I do the red carpet and
then I don't care well in the video when
it was announced that she won that award
earlier in the night oh he dropped Rock
the floor as one would do when you win a
Grammy I would imagine two away one
again during the telecast
she was just head and palms just beside
herself and you know I I feel like she
genuinely didn't see it come in I'm not
sad good luck charm you're a good luck
charm apparently talked to the Grammy
Museum she got nomination you talked her
into carpet it won Best New Artist
you're welcome all right let's talk
about shallow shallow took home the
ceremony's first trophy oh I talked to
Mark Ronson that's right and the other
writers as well Anthony you know I
talked to him off
well Gaga was looking amazing and she
all they won best pop do or I should say
Gaga won Best Pop duo/group Performance
alongside a Bradley Cooper who could not
be there because he is at the bath I did
talk to them about the awards that they
won earlier in the night they had a
group chat going and I asked like what
was Gaga's response to it and they said
more explanation points and emojis that
you can even count a lot it was a lot of
the cowboy boots emoji is what they said
it's kind of insane how you can win a
BAFTA which by the way guys is like the
British equivalent of the Oscar how you
can win a BAFTA any other Grammy in the
same night that's how good shallow is
and thankfully miss Gaga Mother Monster
performed this song live at the Grammys
a different game it was a little
indecision would explain explain why you
think she did this we take a look at it
[Music]
oh they better hire you for the Oscars
she was giving us all of this
hairography can the bedazzle the makeup
it was everything I thought we're gonna
get a little more drum malfunctions at
one point she was rocking out it was not
the version I was expecting though as
much as I love plain why because this is
interesting I feel like the Academy of
Motion Pictures Arts and Sciences are
really strict when it comes to who they
have present and who they have perform
at the Oscars I feel like they probably
told Gaga you can sing this at the
Grammys but only if you do it
differently than what you and Bradley
will do at the Oscars because again
Bradley's gonna perform shallow with her
at the Academy Awards so I think this is
her chance to you know give us a glam
rock Gaga and I do believe we have a
little clip of Gaga from backstage let's
take a look okay how was it being a part
of that amazing over me it was
incredible I'm having so much fun I feel
so blessed I feel grateful I've been a
part of the Grammy community for 10
years now and just to be here to
celebrate all these beautiful artists is
wonderful and I'm just happy for
everyone and I can't wait to perform
that was Lady gaga talking to et's Kevin
Frazier that was actually right after
the opening not after her performance
but good night for Lady Gaga and she
looks fabulous which we'll get into in a
minute you know who else had a good
night was looking fabulous your fave
because I talked to dolly that smile
that you're seeing is because I've
talked of Dolly Parton twice this
weekend Friday night and tonight it's
kind of hard to believe that Dolly's
performance tonight was the first it's
unbelievable I mean the woman still has
it she does she'll has it and she was
dressed to the nines and her sequins and
her glitter and shebang and all that I
don't know do we have a little clip of
her of the of the performance or
anything can we show oh we have red
carpet I will take you let's take a look
at that all right now dolly first
the Grammy stage since 2001 well it's
about time I got you're good in it
we missed you thank you I missed you
June it's gonna be so special tonight I
mean you've got some of the most amazing
performers young performers who are
paying tribute tonight and you know I
saw some of the rehearsal and you were
completely running the show as we'd
expect how was it up there on that stage
with so much amazing talent well it was
exciting singing with all those young
gals all those wonderful artists and
with the music cares honor and so it's
been a nice time for me I just hope I
hold up through the show and sing good
and make everybody happy and enjoy it in
particular you know watching you and
Miley perform together because I know it
goes deeper than just you know respect
you're at your family I mean you're
watching her grow into the artist she is
right now and kind of vocal as she is
right now from your perspective I mean
just a few words on Miley and what she
means to you well Molly is dear to me I
think nollies were the most talented
people I know she's a great host she her
comedic timing is absolutely great great
actress she sings writes great and I
just love her to pieces I'm glad she's
mine
far too kind dolly I loved all these
hours we love you dolly she's a national
treasure but her performance was so good
today
it was just obviously she was joined by
a lot of her a lot of heavy hitters
tonight Kacey Musgraves Mira Morris
Little Big Town it was worth G Miley
Cyrus and then she performed you know
Khan on her own - and it was nostalgic
and like ending with nine to five
altogether I mean all the feels let's
take a look at it right now
maybe the best part about that clip ETS
just jamming out to Dolly Parton well
that was the receipt they were seated
right behind dolly and Chris Stapleton
and that is something that I've been
wanting to ask all three of them on the
red carpet is if they know each other
don't worry I did it
but I just I think it's so funny like I
wonder if they clearly know who she is a
DJ Maria her country music yeah Sally's
an icon you could recognize her
everywhere I believe the classic look
everyone oh yeah
all right guys be Latinos though we're
also representing tonight another
performance that stole the night was
from opening at Camilla Kibeho Ricky
Martin and J Balvin the Latin superstars
performed a mix of Camilla's Havana and
J Balvin 's hit mayhem day let's take a
look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh so cold I got a pour more sparkling
water for Ricky Martin when he comes on
camera I will say so he rushed through
the red carpet so I didn't have a chance
to talk to him but he was always denny
he was right here and I was like shaking
bomb but you know what's so amazing
about this performance first of all what
a coveted spot in the show and they gave
it to Latin artists you know what I mean
because obviously in 2018 I mean we're
in the middle of what I've been calling
a lot of music expansion you know I mean
people it's it's it's cyclical but you
know last year with the showing of
despots eat though I was hoping people
the Latin music would come back in a big
way and they did it didn't end with this
common theme tonight on the red carpet
about the representation exists of all
the crossovers and what it means to all
the Latin artists and they just have so
much gratitude it's so amazing to see
and to include Ricky Martin and this who
you know burst onto the scene at least
in North America at the Grammys you know
back in the day but I also want to
mention that Camilla's performance as
she said was actually a tribute to her
grandmother where she grew up in home
and stuff so I thought it was just
amazing opening to the to the show and
eat she actually caught up with Camilla
right before she took the stage here in
us now what can we expect from your
opening performance you know what um I
definitely feel a little bit nervous
right now but that I think the more
nerves the better the show okay you know
but the base basically it's based on my
family it's based on specifically kind
of my grandma's upbringing she was you
know raised in Havana in this thing
called a salon about NATO which is
basically like a poor person's it's like
a big house but every family has one
room in the house and they there's like
a common patio that everybody shares and
some musicians would go and like Jim out
and stuff and my grandma would always be
there dancing and like singing with
people and so the whole thing is
basically based off that vibe it's like
a big Latin block party so it should
hopefully it will feel like a party it
was she brought the party in Brooklyn
she brought the price she hosted the
party set the tone for the night and
then also I have to say I think she did
her grandma proud well speaking of
parties we're gonna keep this
post-party going so head on over to the
live stream on ET live.com you guys can
also you can also download our app we
are available on roku Apple TV Amazon
fire Android and iOS so stick with us
for all about Grammys everything Grammys
here on UTI cheers go
[Music]